-Welcome back, everybody!
We are hanging out
with John Oliver!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, John, as talk-show hosts,
we have to be knowledgeable
on a wide variety of topics,
and we also need to be able
to think quickly on our feet.
-Do we? Okay.
-Yes. With that in mind,
I thought it would be fun to
play a new game we call
"Ten in Twelve."
-Okay.
-Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Ten in Twelve ♪
-All right,
here's how this game works,
and thank you for always
playing something with us.
-Yeah.
-We're gonna take turns
picking a card from this pile.
Each card has a category on it.
Could be anything -- types of
animals, names of TV shows.
Whatever.
Then we'll have 12 seconds
to name 10 things
in that category.
-Okay. You know the moment just
before you see a car crash?
[ Laughter ]
-Is that where we are?
-We're in that moment right now.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-All right. I think --
I think this could be fun.
-Okay. Okay, sure.
-10 in 12.
-We'll see about that.
-All right, here we go.
-So, you go first.
-I will go first.
-10 in 12.
-Yeah, okay.
-What's your category?
-My category is first names.
I can do this.
-Okay.
-10 first names
in 12 seconds.
Ready?
-Yeah.
-John, Jack, James, Jasper,
Jamie, Samantha, Steven...
-There are other letters.
[ Laughter ]
-...Terry, Larry, and Ted.
[ Dings ]
No?
-Did he get it?
-No, what did I do?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you get it?
[ Dings ]
-Did I do it?
-I lost --
-I got 10!
All right, good.
Harder than you think.
This game's harder --
Now "Family Feud"
seems really difficult.
-I'm more embarrassed by the
fact I genuinely lost count.
[ Laughter ]
-And it was only going
1 through 10.
-I thought I was doing 15.
Okay.
-Well done.
-All right, thank you.
-Okay.
-You are up.
Just tell us the category, and
then whenever you're ready,
that's when we
start the countdown.
-Um, okay.
Holidays.
-Okay.
10 holi-- that's hard.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
This is an audience that has
no faith in me whatsoever.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
10 holidays in 12 seconds.
Whenever you're ready.
-Kwanzaa, President's Day,
MLK Day, Labor Day, my birthday,
your birthday,
Questlove's birthday,
Tariq's birthday...
-Oh, my God.
-Is that not a holiday?
Christmas, Hanukkah.
[ Buzzer ]
-Yeah, I think --
[ Dings ]
-Wait.
You got a buzz and a ding.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think he did it.
Yes, you did it.
That was right down to the wire.
-There was --
-There was
four birthdays in there.
-As long as you're not --
As long as you're willing
to not deny that the...
-Our birthdays are holidays.
-...that birthdays of members
of your staff
are worth celebrating,
then I'm fine.
-No, I would never --
I would never, ever do that.
-That's what I presumed.
So, I think we're good.
Happy birthday, by the way.
Questlove,
his birthday's this week.
There we go.
-Happy birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy birthday.
-Let's do another round.
-Happy birthday to all
who celebrate birthdays.
-All who celebrate birthdays.
-Yeah.
-All right, mine's
words that begin with "B."
-Wars that begin with "B"?
-No, words.
-Oh, I thought you said wars.
-No, not wars.
-I was like, the Boer War.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay.
-No.
Words.
-Words.
-Words that begin with "B."
Here we go.
Uh, uh, uh,
balls, bat, bastard...
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Stop.
Don't do another one.
Don't.
[ Sad tuba ]
Oh, man.
Oh, God, that is --
-That's all
I could come up with.
-There is nothing
I'm happier with
than the nice guy, Jimmy Fallon,
the crack in that,
all it takes is just name three
words beginning with "B."
Bastard!
[ Laughter ]
-I couldn't think of --
-What about "M"?
I guess, uh, mouse, mistletoe,
mother [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It doesn't take me --
doesn't take me much to crack.
Hard to crack the shell, man.
-I think -- I think yours have
been easier than mine.
-Holidays is tough.
Yeah, words that begin with "B."
-Okay, all right.
Ready?
-Yes.
-Parts of the body.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
I got this, I got this.
-Yes.
-Ready?
-Toes, feet, ankles, shins,
knees, thighs, hips, hands,
fingers, elbows, shoulders.
[ Dings ]
Yes.
-You cheated!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, that was good.
A little -- that was -- yeah.
[ Air horn ]
A little cheating there.
Yeah.
Okay.
This next round --
this is the last round.
We're down to the final round.
-Yes.
-Okay?
-Yeah.
-We're gonna
switch things up here, okay?
We're gonna join forces
to see if we can name
10 things together.
-Oh, yeah?
-Okay? Yeah, yeah.
-We're playing as a team now.
-Okay.
-Okay? And if we get 10 --
-Who's going first?
You serve, or I serve?
-I think you serve,
because you're my guest.
-Oh, thank you, Jimmy.
-Well, thanks for being here.
-I appreciate it.
-All right.
We get 10...
-Okay.
-...we're both champions.
And we win -- we win everything.
[ Laughter ]
-Colors.
-Colors. We got this.
-We have to --
We have to get this.
-No, we have to get 10 colors.
-We have to get 10.
Okay. Ready?
-Yes.
-Okay. Don't.
Okay.
Black.
-Blue.
-Red.
-Yellow.
-White.
-Green.
-Pink.
-Lavender.
[ Laughter ]
-Taupe.
-Mauve.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We didn't get it?
-We didn't get 10?
[ Dings ]
Yes!
We got 10!
Mauve!
-We got it?
-Mauve! We got it.
-Mauve was the last color.
-Is --
-Is mauve a color?
-Is taupe a color?
[ Dings ]
Yes? Mauve is a color?
Yes!
Look at us!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Never in doubt.
-John Oliver, everybody!
-"Last Week Tonight
with John Oliver"
returns for its 10th season,
Sunday, February 19th,
11:00 p.m., on HBO/HBO Max.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.